[Music]
it's plenty of time now they're home
[Applause]
[Music]
shoot on sight
I don't know anything
Thank You let's get to me as part of a
covert CIA operation
the man in charge needs to need that
Oh get behind everybody's buying this
you and me we want the same thing some
work with me one condition
I'm gonna kill them all
yeah I can live with that
[Music]
you're gonna see your family
Frank castles back the Punisher he's
dead just look like the work of a dead
man
[Music]
you
hey everybody new Metallica Punisher
let's break it down
Metallica Punisher is the best Punisher
this is gonna be so awesome and there is
a new round of that Thor ticket giveaway
all you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'll name a new winner at the end
of this so the whole thing if you didn't
pick up on it right away if you're not a
huge Metallica fan the song that they
use in this is one it's from way back in
the and justice for all album which is
like classic era Metallica they've
changed their sound quite a lot over the
last 30 40 plus years that they've been
together but and justice for all
probably not their best album but the
song itself is actually very relevant to
the story of Frank Castle because it's
all about the horrors of war they
actually used the lyrics from the bridge
you know landmine has taken my site all
these terrible things that happen to
people and how they deal with it when
they come home and that's all about the
Punishers character you got a little bit
of that during daredevil season 2 so now
we pick up with him in a flashback you
see his wife being killed covert CIA
operation I posted that video yesterday
of him doing those Rambo style takedowns
since then they've also posted an audio
clip of Mike Rowe sort of reaching out
to Frank so if you've been watching the
trailer videos that I posted a lot of
them have this very found footage style
and it's almost like you're watching
them from my crows perspective as he's
hacking into other people's
communication the CIA Homeland Security
FBI hacks into the Punishers comms and
is like you're that guy you're Frank
Castle the dead man The Punisher and he
says yeah I guess that makes two of us
now like because Mike Rowe here found
him out so he's like okay well I got to
kill you now too because you know who I
am but I know a lot of people were
confused because during daredevil season
2 he keeps sitting in that
merry-go-round area in the park and
that's where his family was supposed to
be killed but in this hallucination that
he has somebody comes into their bedroom
and kills his wife that could be part of
his post-traumatic stress or it could be
a genuine retcon but I think we'll find
out through the course of the series but
we pick up with him in present day and
I'm just assuming that this is taking
place after the events of defenders so
Karen page has already been through all
this crap with Matt and they think that
he's dead right now so just continuing
the theme of using that specific
Metallica song they do this really nice
thing where you see him armoring up he's
spray-painting the
go on his armor to the drum solo so you
get that nice rat-tat-tat as he's
snapping the clip into the gun but as he
says in the trailer all the people that
are after him you can sort of
differentiate them based on the way that
they dress so Homeland Security dresses
like this technically they're supposed
to be the good guys the FBI doesn't feel
like they're super corrupt either the
CIA is a little more sinister
because that's who Rollins is working
for you see him pull that mask off
covert torture operation so you just see
him doing all manner of ill [ __ ] The
Punisher has to stop him but it's sort
of this conspiracy that stretches to the
highest levels of government which is
why the Punisher is up against all these
different agencies and for the most part
they think that he's dead but I'm
guessing that Rollins and say someone
like jigsaw who's working with the anvil
corporation sort of like the Private
Merck company that's probably backing up
what Rollins is doing they probably pick
up on him first because they know that
he's one of their former squad mates so
they probably understand him a little
bit better than these homeland security
agents if you wronged someone in the way
that they wronged Frank Castle you would
probably be expecting him to come back
to especially after you hear about what
he did during daredevil season 2 the
implication is is that the blacksmith
from that series was actually working
with Rollins and he was sort of involved
in this larger conspiracy so once he
died they sort of picked up on the idea
that Frank Castle was coming for them
but I love the look of the costume the
armory here is micros like I said you
know he reaches out to Frank and Frank
agrees not to kill him long enough for
them to work together the micro
character is a CIA agent or a former CIA
agent that's become a whistleblower so
he's using all of his skills to gather
this information for Frank I do kind of
like the way that they hacked into the
body cams during that rambo scene pretty
much all these scenes here with him
cleaning himself up between missions is
probably micros hideout you can pretty
much guess Karen Paige's involvement she
shows up a little bit during this
trailer but because she works for the
newspaper it's a little bit easier for
her to drag stuff out into the light
like she could actually write about this
big conspiracy stuff using evidence
gathered by Mike Rowe and the Punisher
to say hey you know all these government
agencies and these people inside them
are doing terrible things in a way
that's harder for those agencies to
suppress the truth so like they say the
has to be taken so I guess you could say
the government is really the villain of
the Punisher series I mean really it's
Rollins and then jigsaw will rise to be
sort of the small bat of this series
probably the big bad of season two I
wouldn't be surprised if he gets
involved with the kingpin eventually -
but because Ben Barnes has that pretty
boy face I'm just curious to see if they
go full jigsaw this season Punisher
takes him down towards the end and he
actually gets those scars from the
comics so everybody let me know what you
think of the trailer I think everybody's
a little more jazzed up the body cam
footage trailers that they were dropping
were kind of janky if you didn't know
what was going on and it was kind of
hard to know what to expect from the
series this is genuine footage taken
from episode so this is much closer to
what it'll look like it'll be
interesting to see what the actual
Punisher sound score sounds like because
series like Luke Cage always use a lot
of a license music but then you have
series like Daredevils it's mostly
original music so it'll probably be a
balance of those two things but the
funny thing is is they're still playing
it fast and loose with the release date
they actually don't uncover the cryptic
at the end of this like oh it's coming
in November sometime 2017 but of course
I'll be doing episode videos when it
gets here so far I haven't had any
problems with YouTube's censorship
because the punters are so hardcore so
when I'm actually doing videos I'll try
to have a little bit of fun with it
besides the standard WTF moments like
The Punisher just feels like it's gonna
be a little bit more crazy than the
other Netflix series so I think if you
were upset with the lack of action in
defenders and some of the other series
like if you felt they moved a little
slowly
I think Punisher will be the nice
antidote to that there'll be 13 episodes
total so just leave all your bonus video
requests in the comments what's gonna
happen later tonight is all post new
Game of Thrones there's probably going
to be a new arrow season 6 trailer - but
I might not get to that till Thursday
morning so don't worry you know big
stuff drops in the next couple of hours
I'll totally fit it into my schedule but
I will hop you up by saying that they
just confirmed that there's another Game
of Thrones
spin-off that they're developing so five
Game of Thrones spinoff series will
compete to the death in the thunderdome
to find out which one is going to be the
successor to the main series so I'll
talk about that when I post that video
congratulations to the latest Thor
giveaway winner party master it looks
like you'll be partying pretty soon
because your tests are almost
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details I'll announce a new
winner when I post new marble but you
can click here for a brand new flash
episode one trailer and you can click
here for brand new Rick and Morty thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight